100 seconds of Silence in Tel
Aviv 100 days too many say the captives
families as they took to the stage at
what's become known as hostage
Square there are 136 hostages there
we're waiting for them all each minute
each second they were kidnapped because
the state failed because we fail and now
we must do everything everything to
release them
November's temporary ceasefire deal
between Israel and Hamas through
mediators saw the release of over half
of the 240
captives their return was promising and
helped provide the proof of Life needed
for some of those left behind but the
deal ended and there's been no sign of
another so
far Israel has rejected hamas's
condition to end the war which has
already killed nearly 24,000 Palestinian
opinions if anything prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu vowed on Sunday to
continue one of the things that's become
clear is that we must wage this war and
it will take many more months that is
why we are bringing a revised annual
budget today it requires us to spend
much more on security than we
planned for those safely back in Israel
the fight for survival has ended but the
agony continues especially for those
whose relatives are still inside
[Music]
Gaza being kidnapped is not knowing if
and when your next meal will arrive it's
feeling suffocated at all hours of the
day and not knowing when you will get to
see the light of
day thousands of Israelis are also
calling for an early election and for
Netanyahu to resign for failing to
protect the country on October the 7th
and for the ability to bring back all
the captives this square has become
symbolic a place that unites a place to
grieve and a place to call for action
with many saying there is no victory
until all the captives are brought home
no matter the price even if that means
an immediate end to the
war this 24-hour rally has demonstrated
a shift towards a more Angry tone from
some of the relatives as they accuse the
government of neglecting the captives
directly addressing Netanyahu saying a
100 days you didn't get rid of Hamas our
borders are still not secure and you
failed to bring them
home Al jazer Tel
Aviv make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer